[Música]
só então bom dia de novo eu vou começar
de uma forma diferente
convidando vocês por favor fechar os
olhos e escutaram as poucas palavras
durante pouco mais de um minuto se tanto
pode ser vamos lá
feche os olhos por favor
fecha os olhos aos seus ouvidos e dá
mais leve respiração ao mais selvagem
ruído do mais simples on a mais sobre na
harmonia do mais violento e apaixonado o
grito das mais suaves razão palavras da
doce razão é somente a natureza que fala
e revelando sua existência
se eu poder sua vida e suas relações de
estruturas de tal modo que um cego a
quem é vedado o mundo infinitamente
visível é capaz de aprender no a diveo
tudo o que é infinitamente vivo
as palavras foram escritas por gueto dos
maiores autores de todos os tempos
provavelmente elas foram inspiradas pela
convivência que ele teve com bolt um dos
grandes naturalistas e considerados por
muitos o pai de ecologia que rumou a
dois séculos atrás ou seja lá no século
18 e já pontuava da sobre a interconexão
que existe entre tudo no mundo ele
falava da causa e efeito que tudo num
sistema que nada nenhum fato podia ser
considerado de uma forma isolada e
inclusive de escrever via o nosso
planeta terra como uma grande teia em
que se você puxar se de mais um fio
podia se é que a trama se fosse desfeita
ele teve chegou a essa conclusão a
partir de suas andanças e também a
partir de seus estudos ele viu como que
a ação do homem por exemplo na américa
do sul na atual venezuela no caso da
época era tudo sobre a coroa espanhola
os países não estavam divididos como
agora é a ação do homem
plantações estão fazendo diminuir o
nível dos rios e dos lagos
então ele começou a enfim a introduzir
essa essa questão a questão ambiental
por isso que é considerado o pai da
ecologia os outros nos seus sóis nós que
foram os índios também tenha seu
principal percepção sobre a conexão aqui
todos nós estamos ligados
agora vou contar uma história que
aconteceu comigo é que lúcio uma
perspectiva completamente diferente
eu estava há um tempo alguns anos atrás
com uma amiga que na época era gestora
de uma unidade de conservação andando de
lancha por um trecho do litoral
fluminense
e de repente a gente foi parado
interceptado por uma lancha muito melhor
que a nossa obviamente no qual estava um
indivíduo que era dono de uma casa de
veraneio de perto e ele nos parou com o
propósito de reclamar o fato de não ter
obtido a licença pra cortar uma estrada
que simplesmente ascender a uma área de
preservação ambiental preservação
permanente uma área de mata atlântica
porque ele queria construir uma estrada
que o levasse que lhe permitisse é ter
acesso a uma enseada de águas calmas na
qual ele pretendia passar a ter o
direito de ancorar a sua lancha assim
evitaria que cada vez que ele fosse
passear ele é tivesse que contornar um
costão que era perigoso apenas as
condições de vento tanto que é apelidado
de cabo horn brasileiro isso costão e
ele está absolutamente indignado por não
ter obtido essa licença pra ele não
tinha o menor problema o fato de que se
ele cortasse a ser citada pelo meio de
uma mata virgem é significasse a
derrubada de centenas de árvores ameaça
varias a sobrevivência de várias
espécies e mesmo e afetar a vida de
alguns caiçaras aquele movimento de
lancha que é passar a ter alguns
caiçaras que viviam da pesca ali ele
achava aquilo normal do mês de maneira
mal comparando com a gente em algum
momento da nossa vida também achou
normal jogar limpa de cigarro em
qualquer lugar na praia enfim na calçada
que fosse eu fiquei estarrecido
com aquilo na brinquei a tecla é falei
assim puxa como é que pode
eu me lembro o hotel enfim minha segunda
pátria
a gente chama pessoas que é portugal a
gente chama pessoas assim poxa eu
brinquei e disse ah se um de descer do
lide estudo
acho que se a segundona de estudo e à
minha amiga virou se para mim isso não é
assim está entendendo ela falou
brincando ele acha que o meio ambiente é
o meu ambiente é percepção dele e fiquei
com aquilo matutando foi não
depois eu pensei psf não é justamente o
oposto
se ele julgasse se ele considerasse o
meio ambiente como ambiente dele ele
jamais faria isso eles jamais seria
subjugar ele não olhariam o meio
ambiente como inimigo a ser dominado a
ser derrubado que for né
e aí eu fui sempre puxa mas isso isso
sempre existiu como é que foi querer um
boto já falava que nunca enfim essas
implicações luz nos ossos centrais que
foram zinco que eram os que são os
índios sempre tiveram isso em mente quer
dizer pra ele não tem separação entre 6
bens natureza o ser humano ele estava
bem como aqueles detidos são
interdependentes como que têm conexão o
pertencimento nem eles sabem que fazem
parte de um todo né a gente não o
contrário nosso instinto predatório vem
crescendo neto tem crescido numa se uma
progressão geométrica né isso é um fato
tanto que quando foi é década de 70 e 80
a própria a onu nem as agências de meio
ambiente ligados à onde sentiu
necessidade de começar a organizar
conferências né tv a rio 92 e tudo mais
e um por exemplo tem uma definição que
hoje em dia muita gente conhece da globo
toulon que é a ex-primeira-ministra da
noruega que foi junto com o morro strong
um dos expoentes do movimento
ambientalista a nível das nações unidas
ela cunhou a ou a definição de
é desenvolvimento sustentável como
aquele em que você supre as necessidades
das gerações atuais 100 é danificar a
prejudicar as gerações futuras né
sem avançar sobre o suprimento das
gerações futuras e no entanto apesar de
hoje em dia essa definição se amplamente
conhecida né
é você dar uma ligada por lá
desenvolvimento sustentável aparece e
tudo mais tá nos carros na carta da onu
café enfim eu a carta da terra dos
documentos oficiais
ele é absolutamente ignorada por grande
parte da população não é tanto que se
vocês forem ver e se esse slide a i
mostra o dia da sobrecarga na terra o
que que é isso é o dia em que a gente
entra no cheque especial ou seja aaa a
humanidade começa a usar os recursos que
chegassem esgota os recursos que tem
naquele ano para suprir as necessidades
e com avanço sobre os recursos que os
estoques que teriam que ser preservados
em ter o próximo ano ante a menos 50
anos atrás esse cheque especial que a
gente entra vencia o dia 1º de dezembro
a esse ano já foi 1º de agosto a
projeção é que o ano que vem seja mais
cedo já em julho e por aí vai que a
gente não tomar cuidado realmente juntar
a gente tá na contramão do
desenvolvimento sustentável a gente está
avançando sobre as nossas capacidade de
reposição dos estoques né
isso é muito perigoso né eu me
pronunciei puxa então quando quando que
começou essa clivagem essa noção se nós
vamos estar juntos tinham essa é essa
percepção que a natureza é um inimigo
você dominado que nem existe um nós
índice um meio ambiente essa separação
essa clivagem e já que a gente está no
fórum de educação né
o papel da escola levando em
consideração que hoje o grande parte da
nossa educação passa pela escola e
também como a márcia é muito bem falou o
papel de outros agentes já que a
educação também não
se restringe à escola né o que a gente
pode fazer pra gente mudar essa
perspectiva pra gente fazer o nosso
ambiente realmente do meio ambiente o
nosso meu nosso ambiente como é que a
gente faz o que houve
neder onde vem essa construção que a
gente acha como universal que na verdade
é uma construção tá bom dia da nossa
sociedade urbano-industrial né gente for
lá pra nossa organização como é que
foram feitas novas grandes cidades não
foi feita em considerando os limites do
dada a natureza não a gente tem que
expandir a área urbana então vamos
aterrar num jantar manguezal vão
construir encosta
vamos já a a cobrir rios o que for
entendeu
só que muitas vezes esquece de combinar
com os russos né
ou seja não combinamos com a natureza aí
quando ela se manifesta de uma forma
mais forte ou seja uma chuva mais
intensa por exemplo que acontece
calce a gente junta isso uma governança
não muito eficiente como a gente volta e
meia se depara né aí desastres acontecem
em maior ou menor proporção vidas
humanas são postas em ricos e risco de
desabamentos alagamentos né gente
no último mês teve alguns episódios
nebben ilustrativos disso
então da mesma maneira que é avô também
[Música]
produção
travou aqui bom continuando da mesma
maneira que a opa funcionou
voltar aqui da mesma maneira que a fiel
escola ela da mesma maneira que a
capacidade da cidade seguiu esse modelo
de organização e claro que as escolas
dentro da área anos não podem ser só
absolutamente diferente de uma escola
numa área indígena por exemplo é bom e
vou aqui trouxe o retrato de uma área de
uma escola uma área indígena totalmente
integrada ao meio ambiente está é porque
nem como eu falei não existe essa
separação para eles eu achei
desnecessário fazer diário urbana que
todos nós conhecemos uma outra escola
emparedada como elas são nas áreas
urbanas né
muitas vezes elas até tem grade é muito
parece outras coisas não têm qualquer
resquício de contato com a natureza
e aí para as crianças acharem nem há
crianças que crescem que são que ficam
muito tempo nessas escolas começarem a
achar que quando vem uma laranja na
árvore que alguém colou a laranja na
árvore ou então que o leite é produzido
por uma caixinha um pulo o outro
consequência disso também é o fato por
exemplo que hoje em dia se tem no brasil
uma legião de crianças subir é obesa
subnutridas não sabem se alimentar
elas não têm mais a noção de por exemplo
naquele balde que tem no quintal da sua
casa naquela pia quebrada que está lá
jogado então no na jardineira da sua
varanda
por exemplo poderia plantar uma calcinha
um tempero qualquer um pé de couve que
tem muito mais valor nutricional do que
por exemplo aqueles o corpo que está
aquele costume geria amarelado naquele
biscoito com 11 gols de isopor de valor
nutricional 0 né
então qual é a proposta é vamos fazer da
educação ambiental uma matéria neh que
esteja presente de uma forma lúdica
criativa
assim na grade escolar de uma mãe assim
tanto quanto as outras ciências porque
não sabe sambar do que na hora
nela e ela tem que ser transversal a
tudo não dá pra ser é a educação a
educação ambiental não dá pra ser um
apêndice de biologia e geografia e urge
trazê la para o centro pra gente parar
de ter esse espírito predatório voltar a
ter a noção de que sabe que faz parte da
nossa vida né
e mais quando a gente é consegue enfim
colocar isso formasse crianças com essa
perspectiva fica muito mais fácil elas
também transmitir em si pelos pais é do
mesmo maneira que as crianças são
educadas elas são educadores é um
caminho de duas vias né isso é muito
importante é eo e a gente tem que parar
também com a noção eu a falsa noção de
que educação é e ambiental é uma coisa
elitista que as classes menos
favorecidas do ponto de vista econômico
no brasil é tem questões mais urgentes
como violência a gente tem que encarar
que por exemplo é uma violência a
qualquer cidadão por exemplo não poderá
ter que encarar três horas de ônibus
porque não pode mergulhar na baía de
guanabara porque ele é poluída o que ele
não pode fazer uma respiração
respirar é acordar em respirar ar puro
porque tá tudo muito poluído e por aí
vai entendeu não ter por exemplo água
potável porque os 11% dos rios hoje em
dia no brasil não tão poluídos
o fato de por exemplo a gente tem uma
rede de esgoto absolutamente precária
nas 55 por cento é do enfim não é
tratada jogado in natura não dá pra
gente ter assim entre as dez maiores
economias do mundo e ainda está neste
estado que isso é uma violência sim é
uma questão de direitos humanos de
respeito né e mais e se você
as pessoas têm que ver que o ambiente é
meio ambiente é a questão ambiental é
uma questão de idade
e assim né e assim você quando você
começa a perceber isso quando você está
conectado quanto à atuação traz
consequências
você passa a ter respeito em relação ao
teu outro né você pensa no outro porque
você sabe que você está conectado que
uma ação tua pode incidir sobre o outro
então é uma coisa que se fique com essa
técnica atividade com a inclusão isso é
muito importante nessa sobretudo nesse
país em que respeito a outro tá tão é
injusto então uma proposta que eu trago
para vocês é realmente incorporar que o
meio ambiente é o nosso 11 meio é o
nosso ambiente é isso que é fundamental
pode ser que vocês me acho uma sonhadora
mas eu garanto que assim qual qual na
música de john lennon eu não sou a única
e o que eu estou falando aqui é pode não
ser novidade para muitos de vocês mas eu
acho que é muito oportuno porque a gente
está no momento da humanidade em que a
gente por exemplo tem o presidente da
maior potência achando que a questão da
aquecimento global é uma balela ea gente
está há menos de um mês da posse de um
novo governo que está seguindo pela
mesma seara que já que shannon está
pondo em risco a nossa adesão ao acordo
de paris está questionando a demarcação
das terras indígenas previstas em
constituição inclusive enfim e
infelizmente e verdade seja dita não é o
primeiro governo a fazer isso pelo
contrário né
eu desde que eu me entendo por gente a
gente sempre é nunca teve um governo que
colocou como prioritária a pauta
ambiental acho que está mais do que na
hora meu desejo eu gostaria que nós como
cidadãos realmente incorporássemos isso
é que fosse o último né
sabe que a gente realmente trouxesse
para a nossa vida com uma questão
central a questão ambiental ela já é
central
falta gente reconhecer e dar o devido
valor a ela ea gente não pode mais adiar
a gente tem que agir agora pra gente
quer ter um futuro a gente tem
e agora afinal como disse recentemente
no artigo né
a gente no caso da cidade ou até fazer
uma brincadeira
vamos a gente pode assim vai mudar a
cidade para não mudar de cidade
no caso do planeta a gente sequer têm
essa opção
então por favor é educação ambiental na
veia muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]